hey patrick congratulations on becoming
an uncle
congratulations on becoming an uncle
thank you how is uh
catherine and the baby doing doing great
just got her a little gift
congrats cheers patrick thank you
katherine schwarzenegger and chris pratt
are officially proud parents
it's pretty magical the 30 year old
author gave birth to the couple's first
child together after celebrating their
one-year wedding anniversary
on june 8th it's a good time we're all
very blessed i feel good man
at the time a source told et that
catherine and chris
have had an incredible first year of
marriage
adding that they celebrated their
anniversary was something small
since their baby was scheduled to arrive
soon and we are going to be reading
an author-approved book because it's my
book called maverick and me
and we're going to take turns reading it
and
hopefully entertain some of you kids at
home due to the coronavirus lockdown
catherine and chris have been able to
spend more time together
pratt had just started shooting jurassic
world dominion
and schwarzenegger was in the midst of
her book tour when the global pandemic
hit
i'm super excited to be able to announce
that today we are officially opening
the launch team for my new book called
the gift of forgiveness
according to our source the newlyweds
are thankful for the alone time they've
had
during quarantine i'm in it baby i'm in
it but it's good it feels good
it's allowed them to enjoy the pregnancy
together plus it's given them time to
relax
and prepare for their new addition i'm
very happy in all areas of my life and i
feel really blessed and really lucky
[Applause]
catherine first sparked pregnancy rumors
in early march
when she gave hosts kelly ripa and ryan
seacrest
an elbow bump during her appearance on
live
at the start of the coronavirus pandemic
e.t
later confirmed the news in april at the
time
a source told et quote the couple knew
going into their relationship
that having kids together was important
to them
so when they found out the news they
were extremely happy
i'm a man of faith and i believe that
god works in
mysterious ways and
gives us signs and gifts
in life while this baby marks
catherine's first
chris already shares seven-year-old son
jack with
ex-wife anna faris congratulations to
the proud
new parents i'm definitely more
optimistic
and eager to see what's next